bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce vendredi 18 décembre
il ya quelques jours le gouvernement
avait recommandé d'autoriser les
écoliers et collégiens à faire l'école
buissonnière
jeudi 17 et vendredi 18 décembre afin de
s'auto confiné avant les fêtes une
recommandation qui n'a pas vraiment plu
dans le corps enseignant et surtout
provoqué l'incompréhension
alors at elle été suivie par les s'élève
à ce sujet nous recevrons bertrand
mesure enseignants à trappes et
secrétaire général du syndicat des
enseignants du premier degré snuipp-75 8
dans l'actualité également à maurepas le
supermarché auchan a investi dans une
machine qui permet de désinfecter les
chariots de courses en trois secondes
une façon de protéger les clients ducobu
de 19 enfin dans l'actualité sportive au
dernier pointage l'yvelinois louis
burton et septième au classement du
vendée globe
comme chaque semaine nous ferons le
point sur son parcours juste avant cela
une information le président de la
république est isolé pour les sept
prochains jours à la lanterne à
versailles
l'elysée a annoncé qu emmanuel macron a
été testé positif au kobus 19 jeudi
après avoir fait un test pcr
il a donc été transféré dans ce pavillon
de chasse versailles est situé dans la
continuité du parc du château de
versailles la lanterne est utilisé comme
résidence d'état de la république
française
selon son entourage le président de la
république continue à travailler à
distance depuis le pavillon
l'actualité c'est aussi la
recommandation du conseil scientifique
de s'auto confiné sept jours avant les
fêtes pour cela mardi dernier le
gouvernement par la voix de jean castex
a autorisé les écoliers et les
collégiens à faire l'école buissonnière
jeudi 17 et vendredi 18 décembre
évidemment cette recommandation a fait
beaucoup réagir et à susciter parfois la
compréhension à ce sujet nous
accueillons bertrand mesure bonsoir
bonsoir
alors vous êtes enseignant je le
rappelle à la trappe mais également
secrétaire départemental donc des
yvelines du premier syndicat des
enseignants du premier degré le snuipp
ep avant de savoir si cette auto
confinement a été suivi dans votre école
attrape comment avez vous accueilli
cette nouvelle
on l'a appuyé un peu comme la rectrice
puisque mardi matin il y avait un comité
technique pour toute l'académie de
versailles elle a fait comme nous l a
appris par les médias
donc une fois de plus l'éducation
nationale est piloté un coût par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale un
coût par le premier ministre est
directement par les médias sans que
personne ne soit au courant de ce qui se
prépare donc c'est beaucoup
d'incohérences beaucoup
d'incompréhension et finalement beaucoup
de comment dirais-je de de presque de
détresse a essayé de suivre un
calendrier qui devient de plus en plus
fou et qui les organisent chaque jour un
peu plus le fonctionnement des écoles et
des établissements du second degré alors
aujourd'hui nous sommes le vendredi 18
décembre
est-ce que ça a été suivi hier et
aujourd'hui cette auto confinement
écoutez moi les échos que j'ai
c'est que ça a été très très peu suivi
c'est vrai que c'est une période un peu
particulière où certains enfants sont
absents parce qu'ils sont tout
simplement malade il peut y avoir
quelques départs en vacances anticipées
le vendredi mais on n'a pas été au delà
c'est à dire que la plupart des parents
ont fait le même constat que nous c'est
annoncer ça mardi pour le jeudi sa fin
qu'est ce que ça signifie
où va-t-on enfin on est dans une
situation qui est de plus en plus
difficile à comprendre et on se rend
compte qu'il ya plus de pilote dans
l'avion que sûr le pilote qui est ou qui
en a 2 ou qui en a trois et que chacun
va dans sa direction propre sans que
personne ne puisse savoir comment
anticiper ce qui va se passer sur le
terrain et dans votre école du coup
attrapée est-ce que ça a été suivi ce
que vous avez un ordre de grandeur dans
votre classe par exemple non c'est ce
que je vous disais on a quelques
absences à la marge mais dont il est
très difficile de savoir s'ils sont liés
à un contexte familial à la volonté des
parents d'éviter aux finances ou une
maladie tout simplement d'accord et
cette absence autorisé pendant deux
jours du coup avant les vacances
scolaires est ce qu'elle a bouleversé le
programme scolaire des enseignants non
non parce que de toute façon
le bouleverser dans quel sens pour faire
quoi une fois de plus divisée l'accent
entre eux qui manque ce genre de choses
à écouter en général les deux derniers
jours avant les vacances de noël ne sont
pas les moments les plus propices pour
mettre en place des contrôles ce sont
des moments où on termine les cadeaux
pour la famille le moment où
éventuellement le vendredi on essaye
d'organiser une petite fête au sein de
la classe et puis les enfants sont
fatigués donc c'est en général pas un
moment où je dirais on n'est plus dans
la vie sociale de la classe
on n'est plus dans les interactions et
puis un peu moi dans strictement dans
les apprentissages scolaires
finalement même si c'est au confinement
avait été majoritairement respecte effet
suivi ça n'aurait pas eu d'impact
finalement sur l'éducation l'année
scolaire des enfants
alors on peut toujours dire que le fait
qu' il y ait moins d'enfants dans une
classe permet de mettre en place
d'autres choses pour certains d'un
certain élèves mais de toute façon ça
nécessite une anticipation qu'il a été
absolument impossible à faire et donc
les collègues assez naturellement ont
fait ce qu'ils avaient prévu de faire
ces deux derniers jours donc ça a été
annoncé mardi dernier il ya eu une autre
déclaration du gouvernement le mardi
soir me semble-t-il cette fois ci du
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer celui évidemment qui
vous concerne
il a précisé que les professeurs qui
avaient une personne vulnérable dans
leur entourage n'étaient pas concernés
par cette auto confinement et il a
surtout déclaré je cite les professeurs
ne sont pas plus contaminés que dans
d'autres métiers
parce que les mesures de protection que
nous avons prises depuis septembre
démontré leur efficacité
quel est votre sentiment à propos de
cette déclaration va écouter les
déclarations de jean-michel lancker de
la profession sont accueillis avec tout
scepticisme qui convient à c'est
quelqu'un qui enfile des contrevérités
qui dans une situation pour qu'on peut
qualifier d'exceptionnelle continue à
appliquer un agenda démentiel sans tenir
compte de la réalité donc
ce mini il n'y a plus aucune crédibilité
auprès des enseignants après tout le
monde c'est le même constat de
l'incohérence que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
comment proposer à des parents de que
leur enfance autocon fidh
quant à eux mêmes sont enseignants et
leur interdire de le faire si on a des
enfants et qu'on souhaite que les autos
courts fines et comme le préconise le
conseil scientifique
encore faut-il pouvoir être avec eux et
tous ne peuvent pas se garder tout seul
donc tout ça c'est beaucoup
d'incohérences c'est beaucoup de com
c'est beaucoup de de maltraitance pour
tout le monde aussi bien pour les
parents qui ont dit quelque chose dont
on sait très bien qu'ils ne pourront pas
l'appliquer on s'organise pas du mardi
pour le jeudi
et puis pour les professeurs on n'arrive
pas à comprendre comment s'il est
nécessaire de tous confinés et bien
pourquoi on n'a pas fermé les écoles
c'était la solution la plus simple on
rentrait dans les préconisations du
conseil scientifique
ces espèces de demi mesures annoncées à
l'encan sur les ondes ne signifie plus
rien et ne font qu'exaspérer les usagers
la profession et à sion est ce qu'il ya
eu des contaminations qui soit d'élèves
ou d'enseignants dans votre école
attrape alors écoutez les contaminations
c'est un sujet dont nous avons parlé
avec le directeur académique le constat
qui est fait c'est que on va dire grosso
modo jusqu'aux vacances de la toussaint
les courbes qui était annoncée de
contamination par l'unsa l'éducation
nationale et celles qui étaient évalués
par la rs concernant la population
scolaire était à peu près parallèle même
s'il y avait un delta qui était quand
même très important depuis les vacances
de d'automne le constat est que il sait
plus des cours parallèles c'est à dire
que celle de la rs augmente et celle de
l'éducation nationale baisse les
chiffres de l'éducation nationale sont
des remontées très partiel très
formaliser et qui ne correspondent
absolument pas à la réalité du terrain
alors il ya des contaminations il ya des
cas contactez la grèce n'est pas
d'accord avec l'éducation nationale sur
ce qui est un cas contacts donc tout ça
mais beaucoup de de dysfonctionnements
beaucoup d'incohérences et il est très
difficile de connaître la réalité des
choses
même si on sait que les enfants sont
plutôt moins contaminés que que les
adultes plus les adultes très bien on
l'a compris merci en tout cas va être en
mesure d'avoir été avec nous sur ce
plateau feu dans le reste de l'actualité
c'est une nouveauté au supermarché
auchan de maurepas depuis quelques jours
le magasin propose une machine en libre
service qui permet la désinfection des
caddies en trois secondes une solution
hydro alcoolique et pulvérisé astri
bergère s'est rendu sur place
c'est une petite révolution à maurepas
le magasin auchan a acheté une machine
qui permet la désinfection rapide des
caddies sert à simplifier les courses
pour les clients puisqu'elle permet de
pulvériser en trois secondes une
solution hydroalcoolique pour
désinfecter le chariot dans ce qui évite
aux clients de devoir le faire avec du
papier sopalin et un pulvérisateur
manuel donc c'est vraiment un plus pour
leur faire gagner du temps la machine
fabriquée en europe a été acheté à une
entreprise locale
simple d'utilisation elle est désormais
en libre service
les premiers temps passé au côté de la
machine pour expliquer aux clients les
retours sont globalement positifs on va
dire qu'à 99 % les clients sont rassurés
et satisfait de ce nouveau service les
clients justement commence à prendre
l'habitude certains restent méfiants
quand d'autres se réjouissent
là c'est tellement rapide que je sais
pas trop on a du mal à se rendre compte
comment te peut être désaffecté aussi
rapidement
mais bon je me plie à ce qu'il faut
faire pour rassurer une maximum de
sécurité pour les autres et pour moi ça
va très vite
en plus c'est jeudi j'avais vu ça à la
télé
je trouve que c'est impeccable au lieu
de prendre du produit nettoyer tout ça
c'est super on dit que sur les poignets
tout ça faut faire attention nous c'est
ce qu'on fait moi je sois sage et donc
si on fait très attention
la machine étant maintenant propriété du
magasin va rester en libre-service au
moins pour quelques mois voire plus si
besoin un accord interprofessionnel de
santé signée ce 17 décembre entre la rs
l'assurance maladie et la communauté
professionnelle territorial de santé est
l'acte le financement de cette dernière
un regroupement de professionnels de
santé sur le territoire du grand
versailles pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins
les précisions de justin brasil la cpps
du grand versailles comprenez
communautés professionnelles et
territoriales de santé vient
officiellement de signer un accord
conventionnel avec elle la délégation
départementale de la rs et l'assurance
maladie
concrètement c'est un projet qui propose
différentes missions permettant
d'accéder plus facilement aux soins et
elle s'inscrit dans le cadre de la loi
ma santé 2022
mise en place par le gouvernement qui
propose des solutions face aux nouveaux
défis du système de santé français
alors là c'est pts du grand versailles a
déjà été validé par les rs au préalable
mais cette signature est la
concrétisation du projet aujourd'hui
c'est la signature du contrat officiel
on qui constitue officiellement cette
cpts et qui dit l'état donc via
l'assurance maladie vous donne un
certain nombre de financements pour
mettre en oeuvre les objectifs qui sont
dans votre projet médical le grand
versailles couvre 18 communes dont 275
mille habitants qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier de ce nouveau service de
santé de ce groupement de professionnels
du territoire
ils sont sages femmes sont infirmiers
kinés ou encore podologue
chacun va continuer à voir son activité
le pharmacien la sage-femme l'infirmier
le médecin mais ils vont travailler
ensemble sur des projets communs à
monter pour faire de la corde
nation et pour permettre une meilleure
prise en charge du patient
l'accord officiellement signé ce 17
décembre entre la rs l'assurance maladie
et ces professionnels acte des objectifs
à atteindre sur cinq ans pour arriver à
une satisfaction aux des patients sur
l'offre de soins
il met en lumière trois missions
principales qui devront être conduites
sur le territoire c'est l'offre de soins
l'accès rapide avec des soins aux soins
non programmés trouver un médecin
traitant il ya beaucoup de passion un
sur dix qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant donc offrir un médecin traitant
à ses patients et puis la coordination
entre les professions de santé au sein
du territoire pour travailler sur ces
trois axes le groupement de
professionnels de santé serait
accompagné et financé par l'assurance
maladie
la cpm a sur l'importance de soutenir ce
projet et les autres à venir grâce aux 6
pts ont fait le pari que les patiences
note sur le territoire notre département
seront mieux pris en charge qu'il y aura
aussi donc grâce à cette meilleure
coordination à ces échanges entre
professionnels de santé comme un de fait
ils pourront avoir accès plus facilement
professionnels de santé ne pas être en
même temps là dans le dans les démarches
rechercher un spécialiste de devoir
solliciter une prise en charge à
l'hôpital trousseau fsa se fera de façon
fluide et coordonnés grâce à
l'organisation et les outils numériques
des professionnels utilisent sur le
territoire la signature officielle de
l'accord permet à la cps du grand
versailles de bénéficier d'un
financement sur les cinq prochaines
années une somme à hauteur de 450 mille
euros au maximum par an l'actualité de
la semaine c'est grégory canale qui vous
la résume en 78 secondes
[Musique]
depuis le 15 décembre le confinement est
remplacé par un couvre feu entre 20
heures et 6 heures du matin les sorties
sont limités au strict minimum et doit
se faire muni d'une attestation
seul le 24 décembre fait d'ailleurs
office d'exception pour fêter noël en
famille il est conseillé dans certains
cas de se faire dépister avant le
réveillon en sus des mines une tania
aussi yann 16 villages pour tester les
habitants des zones rurales
nadir est à chanteloup-les-vignes la
ministre délégué à la ville a rencontré
associations et élus locaux la maire de
la commune fait partie des signataires
de l'appel du 14 novembre cri d'alarmé
pour les quartiers prioritaires
six mois après l'élection d'ali ravet
attrape ses comptes de campagne ont été
rejetés la raison ces actions menées
lors du premier confinement avec coeur
de trappes
l'association dont il était le président
l'élu est en désaccord avec cette
analyse le dossier transmis au tribunal
administratif de versailles un plaisir
la passerelle reliant la galerie auchan
et mon grand plaisir est désormais
rouverte partiellement depuis
l'ouverture du nouveau centre commercial
un litige entre les deux parties bloquer
l'accès finalement elle est ouverte de 7
heures à 9 heures et de 19 heures à 20
heures pour permettre de transiter dans
la gare sncf
et puis cette officialisation la colline
d'elancourt accueillera bien le vtt pour
les jo de 2024 l'épreuve
un temps menacée fait bien partie de la
dernière carte du comité d'organisation
les yvelines accueilleront également le
cyclisme sur piste et le bmx le golf le
pentathlon moderne ainsi que
l'équitation
[Musique]
l'actualité cette semaine c'était aussi
des tests 5 g qui ont été réalisés au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines retenus il ya
un an par l'arcep pour le développement
d'une plateforme d'expérimentation 5g
saint quentin en yvelines s'est lancé ce
jeudi 10 décembre
l'objectif c'est de développer des
usages au service du sport dans la
perspective des jeux olympiques de paris
2024 alors comment ça s'est passé
pendant ces tests une captation par une
caméra 360 degrés quatre cas avec
plusieurs flux vidéo a été réalisée pour
un streaming live en 5 g sur youtube et
ses premiers tests sont encourageants il
devrait être suivi de nouveaux tests en
et enfin comme chaque semaine un petit
mot de voile libinois louis burton est
toujours dans le top 10 sur le vendée
globe 2020 après plus de 50% de la
course réalisé son imoca bureau vallée
ii vient de passer dans l'océan
pacifique
le skipper de 35 ans originaire de
rambouillet est actuellement septième
position sur ce tour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale un classement
qui pourrait être bouleversé dans les
prochains jours les skippers sont tous
au coude à coude
regardez cette vidéo enregistrée par
louis burton 20 millions d'euros
allaient encore voilà on est dans
l'ambiance
pour faire l'amour me suis plus d'un
mois des firmes en une semaine leila
jean le cam lavail la boj a vendu que la
bande à boris herrmann et israël l'état
via ce lien et là ya du bureau vallée
conversation entre boris charmatz mairie
d'amiens allez tu vois bien ça remonte
le moral malgré les avaries
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi dans le 7-8 journal présenté par
grégory canal et à 18 heures et d'ici là
je souhaite un très bon week-end et une
très bonne soirée
[Musique]